vacation Rikin morphine
all new episodes begins Sunday July 30th
at 11:30
hey everybody Rick and Morty is back
it's gonna be so awesome so episode 2 is
gonna be airing tomorrow I'll be doing
videos for all the episodes this season
and in the off season too and because
everybody seems to like it I'll just
keep doing the merch giveaway every week
all you have to do to enter that is just
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's for the Zen monkey
Studio store they sell most of the Rick
and Morty merch but as you can tell the
beginning of that is from the Mad Max
episode from next week Rick man see in
the stone it's just summer being super
hardcore she's a big corner store to the
episode so if you're big fan of summer's
character she's gonna get really
ridiculous but the second one is the
Comic Con preview that they dropped
which is from episode 6 it's the cold
open from episode 6 that episodes titled
rest and relaxation they go to a spa
because they need to relax like they say
at the end of that clip oh my god we
need a vacation
that's what the real episode is there
were a couple big sci-fi references but
is really just meant to be a funny
one-off thing that isn't necessarily
connected to the rest of the episode or
the larger plot line that's gonna cross
over all the episodes they dropped an
unfinished version of this an animatic
form earlier this year I'll play like a
couple seconds of it side-by-side it
kind of hurts your brain a little bit
but it's really cool to see the early
version in the finished version at the
same time just horndog morty trying to
get a swerve on Jessica and her friends
talking about foreskin hardcore
block by Rick and they go up on their
adventure it'll take 20 minutes which is
the length of most episodes six days
later they're being chased by space
sperm in some intergalactic conflict on
the run and it's a bit of a reference
then blowing up the Death Star
these are definitely sperm that are
chasing them they blow the Death Star up
it's also a bit Independence Day and it
also kind of looks like a giant space
vagina just a little bit if you haven't
rewatched season two in a while re-watch
that last episode there's a whole bunch
of ballsacks
in the background of a lot of shots Rick
and Morty's surprisingly sexual with its
background animation and they kind of do
their version of the metal ceremony at
the end of episode 4 but the writing in
the background here actually looks kind
of like Gallifreyan so that might be a
little bit of Doctor Who that they're
working into this but these space aliens
don't look like anything from Doctor Who
so it's essentially them having this
grand huge adventure that they
flash-forward on it's supposed to be
relatively meaningless it's important
for this last moment here with their
like oh my god I need a vacation
in boom there you have your episode but
the other real cool thing is they
release the titles of all of the first
six episodes so you guys already saw
episode one Rick shank redemption we're
watching Rick dancing the stone episode
two tomorrow pickle break is episode
three Episode four is called Vindicator
three the return of world ender which
makes me think of interdimensional cable
like one of those fake movies they're
just two dudes just a couple of brothers
episode 5 is called the world leader Lee
conspiracy in episode 6 the clip we just
watched is rest and Rick slack sation so
these are gonna air one week after the
other there won't be a break they
haven't released the titles of the final
four episodes or what the schedule is
going to be after episode six so there
might be a break in the season or we
might just get them one right after the
other for those of you asking where to
watch it they usually stream it on their
website after it's aired on broadcast
they also have a deal with Hulu and an
internationally I believe they are on
Netflix but if you live outside of the
United States
you can just write how you watch Rick
and Morty in the comments but what will
happen is is because episode 3 is going
to air right after I post my Game of
Thrones video and I'll need to take a
little break I'll post my video early in
the morning so leave all your bonus
video requests for this season
congratulations to the latest merch
giveaway winner
Yoda man please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details while you wait for
everything click here for all my Rick
and Morty season 3 videos and click here
for the trailer for the new game of
Thrones episode thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]